If the movie is good enough the effects won't matter.
You look back at the original King Kong,
and you can tell that's like a puppet,
but the movie is so good, you don't care.
You really feel for that damn puppet when it falls off
the Empire State Building in the end.
A practical effect is anything
that primarily exists there on the set.
The actors can interact with them and they have a real sort of gravity and feeling to them
that computer effects can often lack,
kind of [like] the first big movie that had a lot of visual effects in it was the 1924 version of the movie,
"The Thief of Bagdad", which has all these incredible creations and concoctions and on-screen tricks
that make it seems like there's actual magic going on when obviously there isn't.
The height of practical effects for me
is probably the late 70s and 80s.
*music*
The best special effects are probably in the original Jurassic Park. That was the height of practical effects
and also kind of the start of computer effects.
*shows diagram of a model of a raptor(?) used in the film*
And for the most part they still hold up in a way that a lot of other computer-generated effects of the air at Dome.
I think the "trend-away" really was kinda in the late 90s. You look at something like the Matrix.
It's definitely sort of this watershed
where people were like
"Oh, we can use computers
to make things look really cool."
And then Hollywood just overdid it.
I don't think computer effects are all bad necessarily.
But they certainly have sort of a feeling to them
that they don't exist in any physical reality whatsoever
and that creates kind of a disconnection
between the movie in the audience.
Now in the Hobbit movies
where the story doesn't work as well.
I found myself really distracted,
especially in the most recent one
by these gigantic moments of battle that have no real feeling of, like, weight to them of the characters
like behaving as physical beings in a universe
in particular there's a scene where Legolas
runs up a crumbling staircase
as it's falling out for beneath him.
It takes you out of the movie because it's so ridiculous.
The primary argument for practical effects
is a storytelling one.
It forces you to zero in on what you really want to do.
I think that practical effects necessarily limit you by what is physically capable for actors in a certain situation.